I looked around and I said we're
torturing people we use torture I think
that's wrong I'm personally opposed to
torture but we're using it so I said if
we're gonna use it
we need a jurisprudence of torture oh my
god at jurisprudence of torture how can
you say that you're a monster you're
Torquemada no I'm trying to stop torture
and the way to stop torture is to
cabinet to say all right if you think
you have to use moderate forms of
physical pressure in the extraordinary
case of a ticking bomb terrorists who
knows where a nuclear bomb is in the
city of New York all right
create an exception for that but cabinet
limited indicate and people say no no no
we don't want that we'd rather have the
President or the Vice President or some
people on the ground do it on their own
just don't ask don't tell' a wink and a
nod that's not my way my way is always
to have the rule of law govern
everything that we do
you